let's think about the market for real
estate in a given city so here on the
vertical axis i have plotted rent in
terms of dollars per square foot per
month here on the horizontal axis is is
essentially the quantity of square foot
square foot per month available in
millions so this is one million two
million three million four million five
million here in blue we have the demand
curve and you see as as you have as as
the price is high the demand one way to
view it is that the demand for square
footage is low and as the price is low
the demand for square footage is higher
but what i really want to focus on in
this video is viewing the demand curve
as the marginal benefit curve
marginal benefit curve so when you when
the right that first incremental square
foot that is added to the market that
has a huge marginal benefit but people
were desperate to to get an apartment to
get some place where they could rent and
they could live so it has a huge
marginal benefit and then the marginal
benefit for every incremental square
foot starts to go starts to go down
likewise we can look at the supply curve
and we're going to look at this as the
marginal cost curve as the marginal cost
curve
so the marginal cost of that very first
incremental square foot for the
suppliers for the landlords in the city
is one dollar per square foot so one way
to think about it that very first square
foot we don't know what its price would
have been but let's say that it's its
price was at three dollars if it was and
i'm just making that up in that reality
if the if that very first square foot's
price was at three dollars it would
definitely there's definitely an
incentive for someone to make that first
square foot because their marginal cost
is only a dollar and they could rent it
out at three dollars per month and
there's definitely a incentive for
someone to rent it the marginal benefit
is four dollars and they just have to
pay three dollars for it so it could be
it could be rented out for anywhere or
it would exist or this kind of
transaction would happen as long as its
price was within between one and four
dollars
but you could imagine based on how this
is drawn where the actual equilibrium
price is
the suppliers will keep adding more and
more square foot as long as they can
actually rent it out all the way unt
until the point that the marginal
benefit is equal to the marginal cost so
right over here marginal benefit is
equal to marginal cost it wouldn't make
sense for suppliers to produce an
incremental square foot right over here
if they produce an incremental square
foot their marginal cost has gone beyond
three dollars while the marginal benefit
is below three dollars no one is going
to rent that thing out so we reach an
equilibrium at 2 million we reach an
equilibrium point at 2 million square
feet per month on the market let me make
that line a little bit straighter two
million square foot per month on the
market and at a price of
three dollars
three dollars per square foot per month
and you can look at the total surplus
here in this equilibrium scenario we can
calculate the consumer surplus so all of
these folks this first for this
increment this first incremental foot
someone is willing to pay four dollars
per square foot they only have to pay
three the next one a little less than
four dollars benefit they only have to
pay three all the way to this point
right over here so the area of this
triangle right over here
this right over here is the consumer
surplus
so that right over here is consumer
consumer
surplus
and we can calculate it this is a
triangle i'm assuming actually both the
supply and demand curves are lines so
let's see this has a height of 1 and it
has a base of 2 and so its area is going
to be 1 times 2 times 1 half so that's
going to be equal to
1 that's going to be equal to 1 million
dollars
we're multiplying one dollar
times two million
times one half so that's going to be one
million dollars of consumer surplus per
month let's think about the producer
surplus well the producer surplus is
going to be this area
is going to be this area right over here
that first incremental foot it only cost
those producers one dollar but they're
able to sell it for three dollars so
that's that's that or rent it out for
three dollars and then they will keep
producing keep producing all the way
until they do 2 million square foot and
for all of their square feet they're
able to rent it out for more than it was
their cost to produce it so the area
of this triangle is the producer surplus
this is the producer surplus
producer
surplus
the producer surplus and we can
calculate that as well
this height right over here is two
dollars
two dollars times this width is two
million square feet per month two times
two times one half is two so this is
equal to two million
two million dollars so if you were to
talk about what the total surplus is it
is three it is three million dollars
now this equilibrium rent three dollars
per square foot per month is actually
quite a lot for a thousand square foot
apartment my my last apartment uh was a
a two two-bedroom two-bath apartment it
was about a thousand square foot so that
means you're gonna be paying three
thousand dollars per month for that so
that's pretty high rent that's the type
of rent that you might pay in a in a
city like san francisco and let's say
people start complaining about it and so
the government says okay that rent is
not fair it's too high we want to
introduce some type of price control we
want to introduce rent control
rent control and i'm over
oversimplifying how this works but just
to just so that we can deal with this
model right over here let's say that the
city just sets a a ceiling on the price
per square foot per month so let's just
say that they said set a price ceiling
a price
ceiling of two dollars per square foot
per month
two dollars per square foot
per square foot let me write it this way
two dollars per square
square foot
per month so they set a price ceiling
they set a price ceiling right over here
so given that what is going to happen
what is going to happen and what i
really want to think about is what is
going to be the new consumer surplus and
the new producer surplus i encourage you
to pause the video and try to think
about that on your own
well let's think about what's going to
happen from the producers point of view
it doesn't make sense for them to
produce more than one million units if
they that one million square feet per
month or have have rented or rent out
more than a million square feet per
month because that extra square foot
above that its marginal cost is going to
be more than what they're going to get
so the producers are just going to stop
there and so the producer surplus is
going to be the area
of
this triangle
right over here and let's see this is
two sorry this is one dollar times one
million times one half so this is now a
producer surplus
producer surplus a new producer surplus
under the rent control of 500 000. half
a million
500 000 so we see that the rent control
immediately hit the producers pretty
hard the producer surplus has gone down
dramatically now what about the consumer
surplus so we're talking about a million
units so the consumer or million square
foot per month i should say so now the
new the new consumer surplus is the area
is the is this
is this entire area and so you see that
the at least for this first incremental
million square feet the consumers have
started to win out a little bit and to
figure this out
what the total area is we just need to
figure out what we could break this up
into two sections
we could break this up into two sections
and this is the point
one million square feet at three and a
half dollars per square foot per month
this is right over here the point 3.5 so
we could use that to figure out this
this new area and actually let me do it
in a different color and this green
this green area right over here what is
it going to be well the area of this
thing
right over here
is one-half
high
one-half times one
times one-half so this is going to be
this right over here is 250k
and we add that to this area
right over here which is
one and a half
times one one and a half
dollars per square foot per month times
1 million did i do that right yeah so
that's going to be plus
so that plus this
which is 1.5
million you add these two together the
total consumer surplus so the consumer
surplus
the total consumer surplus is now
1.75 million
1.75 million so the consumer surplus
definitely
did go up in total because it gained all
of this from the producer but let's
think about what has now happened in our
society or in our city we the producers
definitely don't want to put out as many
square foot per rent anymore and it does
look like we have lost some total
surplus for our for our little city here
we have lost out on this entire area and
we can calculate it by looking at what
the total surplus was before the rent
control and what the turtle total
surplus was after the rent control the
total surplus before
so before
the total surplus was the 2 million
producer surplus plus the 1 million
consumer surplus so it was 3 million
after
it is the 1.75 million consumer surplus
plus the 500 000 producer surplus which
is 2.25 million
2.25 million and so what we've lost
what we've lost is the difference here
which is 700
750 000
so this area right over here and this is
per month this right over here
represents the lost the lost total
surplus and this lost total surplus is
750 000 dollars per month is referred to
as the deadweight
deadweight
loss so you can debate about rent
control and is it good is it bad is it
good for the for this kind of dynamic
who who gets what share of the surplus
and this of course is an
oversimplification of a market and even
the way rent control would be instituted
but this is a model for beginning to
think about whether uh i guess what what
happens to the total surplus when these
types of price control price controls
are instituted